Welcome, smiths.
You know why I'm here.
We're going to do the
strength test now.
Now, I'm going to take
each of your hatchets,
and I'm going to
strike this railroad
tie repeatedly and violently.
We're going to see not
what your hatchets do
to the railroad tie,
but what the railroad
tie does to your hatchets.
Matt, you're up first.
You ready?
No.
Well, we're going
to do it, anyway.
This is it.
Jay's got a look in his eye like
he's going to beat the crap out
of that timber, so I'm just--
I'm really worried it's
going to come apart.
[grunting]
[laughter]
Nicely done, Matt.
Your edge is fine.
No damage.
You are slightly out of
alignment with your edge here,
but it's slight, so I was
able to correct easily.
Everything's tight.
Nothing moved.
The handle's just a little
big, but I like having
that flare on the bottom.
You did a great job.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
John, we're gonna do you next.
Jay said he's
going to violently
strike this railroad tie.
He has his violent,
I have my violent.
I like to give hugs and
kisses for my violent.
We will just have
to see what he does.
[grunting]
Nice job, John.
Everything's still tight, so
the leather band-aid worked very
well to hold things together.
You did do a rough
index down here,
but it feels almost triangular.
So it's a little odd,
but it worked well.
Good job.
Aaron, you're up next.
You ready?
Fire away, sir.
All I have is just sheer hope
that this is going to last.
Hopefully it's not going
to tear off, or break
welds, or anything like that.
So fingers crossed, for sure.
There's a problem here.
Gentlemen, there is a
minimum and maximum length
parameter for the
handles of your hatchets.
Your hatchet handle is
over by 3/4 of an inch.
You now have the
dubious distinction
of being the only
bladesmith that's
ever participated
on this show to blow
the parameters on both rounds.
That's a little
bit disappointing
from somebody who has so
much talent, so at this time
I have to ask you to please
leave the forge, Aaron.
Yes, sir.
I'm sorry, man.
That sucks.
It's all right.
I'm a little bummed out.
I should have been a little
bit more patient with it,
and a little bit more
diligent about noticing
the parameters of what I had.
What I've learned from this
experience is measure twice,
cut once.